In the previous example, I had highlighted ironcrutchli and x in red.
They were identifiers, which is a formal way of saying
variable name or function name.
Identifiers are textual string descriptions that refer to program elements.
Things like factorial, s and tmp are all identifiers.
We often call them identifiers because they identify a particular value
or storage location.
We're going to allow our identifiers to start with lowercase letters
or also uppercase letters, and they can finish out
with any number of upper or lowercase letters.
Here we have another uppercase letter as time goes by,
and sometimes people like to use underscores to add readability.
That's totally allowed in the identifier, but we'll say not at the beginning.
You have to start with a letter, but after that you can have underscores.
Here I've shown 6 examples of identifiers,
and I would like you to use the interpreter
to write an identifier token rule for these sorts of JavaScript identifiers.
Try it out using the interpreter.